Apple Amazon and Google they get you
your phones your packages and well allow
you to start weird things on the
internet but these companies are all
synonymous with one other thing jobs
lots and lots of jobs but what's the
economic social and political impact of
thousands of people moving into a town
to work for one company hi guys I'm Omar
and this Sunday we're looking at how
cities try to attract big companies and
how that can sometimes help and
sometimes hurt the people who live there
okay so in case you haven't heard Amazon
led by the richest man in modern history
Jeff Bezos has been on the hunt for a
second corporate headquarters otherwise
known as HQ - and while despite being a
somewhat open process it's been one hot
mess to put it bluntly this is only the
sixth big public auction in US history
it provoked 238 bids including many from
places that don't have a prayer that did
not meet the original criteria if you're
wondering why so many cities applied to
host Amazon's second headquarters it's
because well it potentially means tens
of thousands of new high-paying jobs
it also means five billion dollars to
local companies who only charged with
building the structures hiring people
who will then get paid and contribute to
small businesses across the city
all-in-all hq2 presents could really
help the economic growth of the winning
city by its own projection Amazon added
38 billion dollars in value to the
Seattle economy this year Amazon
narrowed its list of finalists down to
20 cities which included Boston
Washington DC Atlanta Los Angeles
Columbus and Miami these cities have
tried to attract Amazon by flaunting
their modern transportation systems and
available housing infrastructure as well
as their cultural educational and
financial institutions some cities like
Boston have even reimagined entire
neighborhoods to make way for HQ to
check out this video the Boston
submitted with its bid
[Music]
sounds great right
except Amazon might be looking for a
whole lot more than that in the form of
tax incentives from those competing
cities they've been told that you need
to offer long term deep tax discounts
property tax abatements sales tax
exemptions income tax credits companies
are like people they they pay three main
kinds of taxes income sales and property
and in many cases especially for big
deals those taxes all go away for a long
time so you might think wow
Amazon's pretty ballsy to expect all of
that well Amazon's gotten a lot from his
years in Seattle allowing it to become
the second most valuable company in the
world at 768 billion dollars just this
year but while Amazon's fortunes have
been on the rise the same can't be said
for its hometown
despite Amazon investing nearly 40
million dollars in housing for Seattle
the city has seen the cost of housing
skyrocket since 2010 more than a hundred
people a day had been moving to the city
and the surrounding area in the last
five years housing prices have shot up
by 70% with median rent in Seattle
hitting one thousand four hundred forty
eight dollars in 2016
coming in at fifth overall nationwide
and despite the increase of thousands of
high-paying jobs in the city the rate of
homelessness has increased by close to
50 percent between 2011 and 2017
again you know economically zero
unemployment in my city and I got
thousands of the homeless people that
actually are working and just can't
afford housing so that's what's been
happening in Seattle and now Amazon is
looking for incentives in the next city
it moves to oh and by the way Amazon
does not receive any tax incentives from
Seattle it's only there because it was
founded in the city and maybe the fact
Washington State doesn't have any kind
of income tax we know that two bids
three bids exceeded seven billion
dollars from st. Louis Newark and
Montgomery County Maryland and this is
going to be perhaps the biggest subsidy
deal in US history
it may rival the eight point seven
billion dollar deal that Washington
State gave Boeing five years ago and
these incentive deals are actually
pretty common states and cities will
often throw this kind of money
companies like Ohio's 120 million
dollars to GE between 2007 and 2011 and
Wisconsin's 3 billion dollar subsidy
deal that went to electronics
manufacturer Foxconn and that's just a
drop in the bucket for these types of
deals between companies and local
governments and across the u.s. studies
have shown that the total amount of
subsidy deals for corporations could be
worth anywhere between 45 and 90 billion
dollars the rate at which these deals
are made has also tripled since the
1990s but this phenomenon goes way back
the history of incentives goes back to
the late 1930s Mississippi created the
first program intentionally designed to
lure companies from the Midwest and from
the Northeast the whole system really
took off especially after World War two
when the interstate highway system got
built starting in the 1950s and by 1976
there was a cover article of
Businessweek talking about the second
war among the states that is the war for
jobs naturally these deals have
generated much controversy over the
years and in 2006 the Supreme Court
overturned an Ohio court's ruling that
said such deals were unconstitutional we
don't have a federal industrial policy
to rein in the states from spending
excessively in these chases or from
actively pirating for each other when
free trade deals were being made left
and right in the 80s and 90s and factory
after factory either shut down or moved
abroad many cities and states sought to
attract other industries for their work
forces enter the tech industry as tech
took off in the u.s. in the 2000s local
and state governments start to compete
once again to woo these companies to
replace the long gone factories ensure a
lot of big tech companies have their
home base in Silicon Valley but they've
also opened up data centers the store
the immense amount of data that they
generate 26 states have created
incentive programs to bring in these
tech data centers and a report found
that Google Microsoft Facebook Apple and
Amazon have received two billion dollars
in subsidies for 11 data centers in the
past decade so with that much money
being spent by tax payers to build data
centers left right and center you'd hope
that there'd be a lot of jobs as a
result right well the study also found
that these data facilities only employ
under 200 people on average and these
states had spent roughly two million
dollars per job
created we can point to examples of
incentives that have worked and usually
those are programs that don't benefit
one program hugely but instead target a
whole industry but while it's possible
for a local government and the dominant
industry to work together to better a
city or a state there's still the
question of over reliance on a single
industry take Detroit for example for
about 70 years Detroit was the home of
the American auto industry but when
international competition grew it became
more expensive for the industry to
remain in Detroit with the numbers it
had in manufacturing and employment as
the auto industry started to leave the
Troy the city's economy collapsed today
the once thriving city is a shell of its
former self but the state of Michigan
wasn't quite done enticing the auto
industry Ford GM and Chrysler were
awarded tax credits worth 4.5 billion
dollars on the condition they keep
eighty six thousand jobs in Michigan
through 2032 by 2015 Michigan was facing
a 289 million dollar budget shortfall
for the tax credits have largely offered
to the auto industry over the previous
20 years 289 million dumped it does
Flint even have clean water yet no if we
pick smartly and pick companies that
have a future we can grow the whole
industry over time and also makes
increase the likelihood that the
companies will stay put in that area
because they see value in being tied to
the local university of the local
training program so given how little so
many cities and states across America
often get out of the presence of these
massive companies many of them have
started fighting back
including Seattle last year Seattle
proposed what was called an Amazon text
that would see Amazon tax two hundred
and seventy five dollars for each
employee something that they could have
easily afforded while attacks was not
completely aimed at Amazon the tech
giant was certainly the main target the
City Council unanimously passed the
resolution but only a month later as the
City Council faced intense pressure from
Amazon and business leaders in the city
it was forced to repeal the resolution I
don't think head taxes are the best way
to approach this deal I think that you
have to have a comprehensive approach we
know how to do this with it's called
community benefits agreements but the
idea of an employee head tax is popular
far beyond Washington State about 43
miles from our San Francisco studio
Mountain View we're close to 40% of the
workforce was employed by Google there's
a proposal for what some have called the
Google tax and we decided to go talk to
the mayor of Mountain View this guy
Lennie Siegel who helped introduce the
proposal for the new tax that would make
companies like Google pay a head tax for
every employee Mayor Siegel's lived in
Mountain View since 1972 and while he's
seen it change a lot its core culture he
says hasn't before Google was in
Mountain View Mountain View was a
thriving tech center we're actually the
birthplace of Silicon Valley there's
been a gradual transition in Silicon
Valley away from physical manufacturing
to software and services and Google is
one of the companies that represents
that the tax which isn't officially
called the Google tax by the way would
charge all companies in Mountain View
attacks per employee based on the size
of the company that yearly tax revenue
could amount to over three million
dollars almost half of which would be
coming from Google and four perspective
right now all businesses in Mountain
View pay a yearly thirty dollar flat fee
regardless of size that brings in about
250 thousand dollars to the city now
it's worth noting that Mountain View
never offered any incentives to Google
instead because of the pre-existing
knowledge from the semiconductor
business and NASA Google was attracted
to the city but why is Mountain View
need this extra tax so it's a problem
for our communities and in fact a
problem for our employers housing here
is extremely expensive the value of my
house has gone up maybe by 20 times
since I bought it in 1972 and we don't
have transit other than Cal train to get
people to work and the mayor's not
worried about alienating companies with
this tax because he knows that the lack
of affordable housing is scaring away
potential employees the tax that we're
proposing is so small compared to the
payroll of any of the companies that are
here that we don't think it'll have any
negative impact on their plans to
continue doing business or even to
expand here so is this what our fiscal
future looks like stuck between bad
incentive deals and coaxing companies
into paying their fair share there may
be times where incentives will work but
by and large the best way to it create a
sustainable business community
is to focus on education to focus on the
quality of life to protect the
environment make it a place where people
want to live and for companies like
Amazon that might be prime advice sorry
about that guys
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and come back next week for another
great video